what is the temperature where you're
located I have to look mine up I have no
idea but I can tell you it's warmer than
it's supposed to be which makes me happy
so what is the temperature and you got
to tell us Fahrenheit or Celsius so
we're not all too confused what is the
temperature where you are I want your
somewhere warm I'm gonna have to go to
Fahrenheit it's 85 here 85 very nice and
where's that Chicago Oh Chicago me too
Oh mine's 83 I'm a little cooler maybe
out in the suburbs anyone else want to
tell us what the temperature is feel
free to just on me yourself or type it
in like we're all pretty warm global
warming is the thing I guess it's 48
degrees here in Danville California 48
Fahrenheit Farren it's a little cooler
there huh all right and then let's go
ahead and find out what nano degree
you're all in that would be really I
that I always like to know that because
sometimes that does help me guide the
conversation a little as we go so if you
want to type in which nano degree you
are taking 59 Cupertino
that's cool out there you can talk to me
about cool in February in Chicago not
fun
which nano degree are you in
self-driving cars digital marketing
digital marketing all right who else
predictive analytics who else wants to
let us know self-driving cars
very good
all right I'm gonna
presentation here in just a second as
you all are letting us know your nano
degree if everyone can just for the sake
of background noise keep yourself muted
and use the chat box anytime you have a
question if I don't get it to it
immediately my colleague Rachel is also
on from Udacity she can help us answer
some quick questions if I don't see it
or I will get to it as I am talking if
you could just make sure you're muted
and
that way we don't have background noise
but if you can't type and you need to
ask a quick question totally fine to
unmute yourself and speak up so we will
go ahead and get started we are gonna
talk today about skills gaps and
weaknesses I know all of us have had an
interview when you get faced with that
dreaded question what is your greatest
weakness and it's never a fun one to
talk about and in fact I think I used to
have the philosophy that I thought it
was a terrible interview question and I
think it's a terrible one that you have
to answer but I actually think it's got
a lot of validity as to why they ask it
so we're going to talk about why they
ask it but more importantly we're going
to talk about strategies on how to
answer it
those of you who haven't I haven't met
yet my name is Angela I'm one of the
career coaches here at Udacity I worked
in finance for many years had my own
business lived overseas and originally
from America but also lived in Australia
many years in China and in Singapore
I worked now as a corporate trainer and
career coach and I specialize in
obviously helping people with their
careers and then also communication and
presentation skills
oh it's 19 in South Africa that sounds
wonderful right now okay we've got a few
more coming in wonderful thanks all of
you for joining we are just getting
started so what we're gonna talk about
today for about the first 40 minutes
we're gonna understand why interviews
ask about our weaknesses and our skills
gaps then we're going to talk about
really why we should have a growth
mindset and why that helps us around
this question then I'm gonna help you
think about ways to identify the gap and
weakness that you might want to talk
about and we want identify maybe things
that you could be doing have done or
will do to overcome these issues then
we're gonna talk a little bit about how
you'll develop that narrative to address
the skills gaps and weaknesses then I'm
going to try to save about 20 minutes
towards the end for a Q&A session and
that can be on anything we discussed
today or anything to do with careers and
coaching that you might want to ask
about I know it's been a little hard to
get some appointments for coaching but
that's getting ready to change we have
new coaches coming on very very soon so
keep an eye out for that so what is your
greatest weakness and yes we all dread
the question it's a question that you
will probably get in every single
interview and it's sometimes asked in a
few different ways so they can try to
get to that answer
so here are some different ways you
might hear this question but kind of and
it's nice to read through these so that
you're you know what they really want to
know is what is your weakness
so they might say what is your biggest
struggle at work or what do you wish you
were better at what are some of your
weaknesses
where are you weakest skills but do you
consider to be one of your weaknesses
what would you consider your boss say is
your weakest area or tell me about a
time you failed these are all different
ways they might ask the question and you
know when they ask us they're really
getting out what is your weak point what
is the part that you wish you were
better at and I often like to think of
it as what do I wish I was better at
because I when I coach a lot of people
when they try to think about the right
weakness we all know we have a weakness
that's that's not any big secret right
but it's the one that you really are
comfortable talking about that's
professional that you want to address in
the interview settings that's really
important and I often like to think of
it as what do I wish I was better at
because that helps me really get to the
root of what I think maybe my weakness
is and I'll just say one of my
weaknesses right now is sometimes when
I'm I've kind of gotten to the very end
of a project or presentation it's that
define details at the end if you noticed
I had a little typo in my slides that I
just noticed when I was reading it that
is definitely my weakness and it's funny
I started out as a financial analyst so
maybe that's why I wasn't doing that
anymore I can have a lot of attention to
detail for a while then I get to a point
where I'm like I'm done so for me that
is
I know weakness and and what I do to
overcome it and we'll talk about that
step next is really I usually find
someone I partner with who can help do a
QA check for me just look at it check
the quality make sure I don't have typos
make sure you know Rachel knows make
sure I don't have weird fonts happening
because that's where I know I need that
extra partner to work with
so why do they want to know my weakness
and you think about it's the iceberg
right they see of course you're showing
your best side in your interview and
like an iceberg like we know we only see
so much on above the surface right
there's a lot under the surface that you
want to get at I'm sure maybe many of
you have hired someone or you know
someone that after you get to know them
a little better or work with them you
suddenly oh oh now I'm finding out
what's underneath the surface now I'm
getting a little more depth and maybe
that would have changed your hiring
decision all the time but when we know
the type of person that were working
with and what that weakness might be
maybe we know what the other weaknesses
on our team are and we need to make sure
this person can help their weakness and
where are they strongest and where might
there be a gap so those are all things
that we can be thinking about about why
they want to know that weakness so first
they want to know are we
we're enough to know our weaknesses if
someone says I don't have a weakness or
I don't know what to say my first
thought is they probably don't know
themselves well enough and it's really
important important to be self-aware in
the workplace and are you humble are you
humble enough to say hey I kind of sink
at this now we're not gonna say that say
it that way in the interview but we all
know there's something we're not great
at and can we be humble and do you look
for areas to improve in yourself
remember that that phrase what do I want
to get better at what do I want to do
better and that really helps you think
about that growth mindset I want to
improve I want to get better and then
think about what are you doing to
overcome your weakness and for a lot of
you it's taking that nanodegree and
taking costs and maybe that's maybe that
was your weakness a certain skill that
you need you knew you needed to get
better at
and that last one do you have a growth
mindset so let's look at that growth
mindset I'm sure a lot of you have heard
about that phrase that something that we
all are talking about now is embracing
this growth mindset there's a lot of
great books out about it one of my
favorites is actually by Carol Dweck
it's called mindset if you're interested
in learning more but really that growth
mindset is saying I can I can learn to
do anything I want I can do anything I
want if I work hard and and put in the
effort to do it now there's some things
I don't want to do I don't want to get
better I don't have a desire to run a
marathon so yeah maybe I can do it if I
really wanted to but that's not
something I'm trying to do but someone
might be but and it's also showing that
failure or Choa or change is an
opportunity to grow so just like you
hear all the time people that run very
successful companies had 12 startups
that failed before they actually made it
right so always remember that failure is
an opportunity to grow have that growth
mindset believe you can do anything you
want understand the roadblocks and the
challenges that you might face is what's
going to make you better and using those
examples in a in an interview where you
can talk about this is why I know I
needed to get better at something this
project wasn't successful or as
successful as I would have liked it to
be because of X so I'm working on
getting better at that and it's a lot
about your effort and your attitude
determining your abilities not something
you were born with and it's showing that
you're inspired by this assess of others
like working with people who are
successful learning from them growing
and pushing yourself and really it's a
lot about trying new things so I think
that a growth mindset and a positive
attitude really go hand-in-hand and when
we have that growth mindset we're saying
yes there are things I can get better at
there are things I want to be better at
and when we have that attitude we
typically will then push ourselves a
little further
and maybe go into jobs and interviews
that maybe we're not a hundred percent
qualified for yet well mate we're
qualified we might not tick off every
box but we're close enough that we know
we can put in the effort to get there
and be successful in that role
so what does a fixed mindset look like
let's talk a let's look for a second at
what we don't want to be we want to
avoid this where you feel like that
failure if you failed one set that
you're done that you that's where your
limit is that's where you have to stop
it's believing that you're either good
at something or you're not it's thinking
that your abilities can't change you can
do it or you can't it's often times to
go through more of a negative attitude
that don't like to be challenged
they give up easily they cannot take
feedback they stick to only what they
know and if any of you have had children
or you remember your parents saying it
to you these are you know you always are
teaching your kids that growth mindset
you can do what you want you can put
your mind to it you can work hard and
keeping that mindset that you want it
instill in your children and making sure
you have that in yourself or if you
remember your parents saying it to you
this is why they want you to challenge
yourself and push you even further so
that's where having that growth mindset
really helps us take a positive spin on
our careers where we believe we can go
and in this interview process it can
help us look at this weakness question
without fear or or being hesitant to
talk about it
so how do you decide the weakness you
want to discuss this can be tricky
obviously first it needs to be
work-related
it can't be well you know I was never a
very good singer and that really has
been a hard thing of my life like that
can't be your weakness because that has
nothing to do with the job they want to
know a weakness that is a weakness
related to your profession and your job
it needs to be authentic
it can't be an off-the-shelf a weakness
that you've heard other people say and I
have had a lot of people try to use
those kind of canned responses people
will see right through it and it
typically needs to be non-essential to
the job you're applying for
so non-essential means you know if the
job you're applying for it needs you to
have very strong proficiency in Python
and you just started taking intro to
programming that's probably a pretty
essential weakness I'd be surprised if
you were even sitting in the interview
at that point so making sure that you're
not thinking about your weakness as a
core responsibility in that job and it
should be something that's minor and
fixable something that you can work on
either you get better at or you have
tools to be better at it and we'll talk
about some of those and ways that you
can talk about it and we'll have time at
the end where if you kind of know your
weakness but you're not sure how to talk
about it you can bring that up and and
obviously it means something so you can
work on it maybe you're already working
on it or you have an idea of how you can
be better at it I'm going to pause for
just a second and if there are any
questions at this stage please feel free
to type them in if you need to unmute
yourself bring it up we still have quite
a bit to cover but just make sure that
everyone knows you can type in questions
at any time
what not to say and I love that little
monkey never say I don't have a weakness
that like remember that that
self-awareness that humbleness that's
like you've just lost it all right there
or we're an old way of telling people
how to talk about a weaknesses my
weakness is X but that's actually a
strength because bla bla bla and a lot
of times you'll say my weakness is I'm
I'm a perfectionist but that's actually
a strength because I can do very
detailed work like that's just not
giving someone what they're looking for
and then the bottom through your thick I
think the three that I really dislike
the most and I think a lot of recruiters
and interviewers as well as when people
say I work too much I work too hard I
take on too much or I'm a perfectionist
stay away from those those are saying
that you're not humble you're not
self-aware and you don't really have a
grasp on maybe what your true weakness
is and those would be red flags in it
interview so definitely stay away from
those
so what do you say is a layoff a
weakness that's an interesting question
I think that a layoff that could be a
weakness you know and it could be that
that you feel like your weaknesses is
maybe a gap that you've had in your
career because of a layoff maybe it's
the confidence that you felt like you've
lost a little confidence as a result of
a layoff so think about like in terms of
the layoff what was the what happened
after the layoff to you to kind of make
that a weakness was it a big gap was it
a the confidence level was it being out
of the market or something for a certain
amount of time so what was the symptom I
guess of that layoff and and absolutely
you can use that somewhere I think I
kind of touched on that like yes that
gap when the career can definitely be a
weakness
so I put together this listen I know I
said don't take anything just off the
shelf which of course you don't want to
do that and off the shelf I mean are
typically ones that say oh you know I'm
a perfectionist and I do this or that
but think really think truly about
yourself and give an example about where
that weakness comes and these are
weaknesses that are often discussed in
interview settings I kind of hold these
from various different sources that I
follow and talking to different people
who do a lot of interviewing so as you
look down that list I kind of wanted to
provide this more than anything for you
just to help you think through some and
think through some ideas if you're not
sure how to address it
so kind of just running down those
teamwork maybe you're someone that likes
to work really independently and you're
not as good at maybe speaking up in the
team or or liking when there's a lot of
talking and action in one spot you
prefer to be in a quieter space maybe
time management struggling with
deadlines in that case maybe thinking
about different tools you could use
delegating is a big one up here at
management levels sometimes feel like to
hold on to their work and they have a
hard time empowering their employees
having patience maybe in a new setting
with new employees focus it could be
that maybe a little like me I have a
little focus for only so so long on a
project and I kind of starts to lose
interest and I'm ready to move on to the
next one shyness maybe you're afraid to
speak up in meetings your organization
skills may be that your desk has stuff
all over it and you kind of look
disorganized but that you know you kind
of have a system and you try to change
that a little bit for other people
detail-oriented maybe and hopefully if
you're not detail-oriented you're not
going to be an actuary or someone that
really needs to be detailer in it but
you know maybe your marketer and that
your ideas are big and when it comes to
details of putting something together
maybe you struggle a little bit your
writing skills sometimes especially if
like I've got foreign language down
there later sometimes if English or
wherever you're living isn't your first
language and you're needing to write or
communicate that language using that as
your weakness
public speaking is a big one everyone
has to do it these days right get up and
talked about it that's an easy one to
talk about maybe where you struggled but
have found sources to get better being
spontaneous some people really don't
like when they are called in a meeting
or asked to get up and speak really
quickly they like to have everything
very planned and they like to process
more multitasking maybe you're someone
that really likes to work on one project
at a time and juggling a few things it's
a little harder for you
foreign language I mentioned and then
obviously this hex skills and that is
usually hopefully again we won't do well
doesn't why we don't want it to be the
number one skill they need in the job
but maybe it's a one of the skills they
might be looking for it and you're
taking a class and getting better at it
something that from the chat box just to
jump over to that really quick is
talking about the gap and how do we
highlight this or choose something like
it from yours and I'm gonna get to that
in just a second Amer just so you know
if you haven't seen it already there is
also a web and I did recently in the
last few months anyway
on addressing a gap in your career
specifically so you might be interested
in that one as well
we have a YouTube channel with with most
of the webinars that have been recorded
that you can go back and look at those
this one will be there within a couple
days and you can find the gap in your
career there as well
so again that's kind of a big list of
just again to kind of get your wheel
spinning to think about if one of those
might work for you
grant is asking can location be a
weakness I think that is the weakness of
the location probably not your weakness
maybe what how you could put that into a
little perspective as if you feel like
you haven't gotten sophisticated enough
companies to work with because of your
location
maybe you could spin a little bit that
way what is the name of the YouTube
channel maybe Rachel if you couldn't the
next few minutes post the link to the
YouTube channel
I believe it's Udacity and then we have
a careers section in there but maybe if
Rachel gets a minute if she doesn't have
a minute to do that for me I will get it
for you towards the end here I want to
thank you very much for sharing so the
link is there thank you Anna
and reach I've got it as well wonderful
okay so again we're thinking about what
fits me and obviously it's gonna be a
very personal decision
but hopefully this list helps you think
of some common weaknesses that are out
there that you could have an example for
and think about how to address it so
this is a list of questions that I think
helps you dig out again it's that
self-awareness and thinking of how you
can figure out the right weakness and
sometimes people aren't really sure of
what their weaknesses and sometimes even
having a peer to talk to it and ask and
and think about it well let's go through
these questions is there a task I dread
doing in my case I know it's something
that I mentioned earlier that I just
don't like to do so I save it till the
last minute and then I try to do it
really fast so I know that's not the
best way so sometimes when you you know
it's something that you dread it's
usually something you're not real good
at either and maybe you could be decent
at it but because you save it till the
last minute like that thing on your
to-do list that's always never scratched
out it keeps just getting on the the
next day keeps getting pushed there and
then finally you're like okay I gotta
get this done that might be your
weakness and think about is there
something I really struggle with it
where because there's something that
takes longer than it should is there
something you really always have to ask
for help think about if that's something
or did you manager ever point out
something that they want you to improve
maybe was in your performance review
maybe it was in a conversation maybe it
was a debrief from a project maybe it
was a mentor on a Udacity course that
was that pointed something out to you
but think about has someone ever pointed
giving you feedback or criticized you
for working a certain way or the your
performance in a certain way and think
if there's a way you can think about it
that way again if I had a performance
review or if you've been in a role where
you've gotten a 360 survey where they
asked a lot of the people around you to
get feedback usually anonymous so it's
pretty honest feedback and see if
there's something you can find there
sometimes and even given that if you
take a personality assessment if you've
done myers-briggs or discs or
16pf ma the big assessments sometimes
those will help you think about what is
out there that might be your weakness or
if you haven't had a chance to do those
they can be quite expensive there's a
lot of little mini free versions online
where you could do a little mini
personality assessment not those weird
ones that say like what are you gonna
look like when you're older anything
like that but if you look disk or
myers-briggs free version you might find
something out there you know Tony
Robbins happens to have a free disc
version but he'll just give you it's not
as in-depth but you might get highlight
something that you hadn't thought of
the last one says was there anything
problematic when I was studying or
working on a project you know when you
think about different projects you've
worked on or when you've been studying
something that you really struggle with
and and sometimes a weakness could be
something that has been a weakness for a
while but you've gotten to the point
where you've really gotten better at it
and you're building your confidence and
that's a way to talk about it as well
you don't want to end it with like no
it's my strength because then they're
gonna say well tell me about another
weakness so you might want to say like
my weakness has always has recently been
or over the years has always been X but
I have been working I've been taking
these classes I've worked with a mentor
and I really feel like my confidences is
getting better and I'm noticing myself
getting faster with this each time I do
a new project I want to ask how do I
address patients in that case you might
think about what are some if you're
impatient with your staff or an employee
with decisions being made think about
maybe what what do you do at work to
help yourself from not just going and
yelling at everybody right and saying
okay I know I'm being impatient what can
I do to make sure that I handle this
right is it that you maybe outline a
to-do list and talk to everyone and find
out the status from everyone is it that
you set deadlines a little sooner than
you actually need them because you know
that you're gonna want it a little
quicker anyway so maybe think about some
of the the workarounds that you've done
in your jobs and projects to help you
work well with people while kind of
raining and maybe some impatience
so I'm going to go through a little
two-part answer strategy that I think
can help you you might have seen this
before when we did a weakness workshop
and then I'm gonna give you a few
examples first state your weakness just
say what it is quickly make it snappy
next explain what you're already doing
or intend to do to overcome this
weakness and I've kind of walked through
a few examples as I've been talking but
I'm also going to show you a few here to
think about how you could address
certain weaknesses
so this one I don't have a lot of
experience with back-end development
what I might say however I have worked
in front-end for the last two years and
worked closely with the back-end
developers I've also recently completed
completed the Udacity nano degree in
full stack to expand my skills in that
space then I might go into a little more
detail but you can see how the weakness
was that lack of experience but you
you're overcoming that because you
worked closely with people so you're
very familiar and you also took a class
so that you could become refine those
skills even more as a new manager I've
noticed I'm not very comfortable as
delegating tasks but I talked to an HR
manager and received some tips and
resources to be a better delegator I
learned to outline the tasks and timing
in detail first so that I'm more
organized when talking to my direct
reports and this has helped me to be
much more effective so I wanna ask about
patience this is kind of a way when
you're talking about a soft skill where
you can show you are working on that
skills think about ways that you have
resources you tapped into things that
you've done to manage that weakness
you
I've struggled in the past with
effectively presenting my data insights
so I asked my manager her if manager if
I could enroll in a presentation skills
course she was very supportive and I
completed a two-day training and help
equip me with new skills and I'm feeling
much more confident when presenting so
you can see it's still my weakness but
I'm feeling better about it I'm working
on it
again it's that growth mindset it's that
willingness and showing you're putting
in the effort and I'm aware of what my
weaknesses
you
then you just always hope they don't say
what's another weakness so I do always
recommend to have to ready because that
gets tricky when they ask for that
second one
so again ways to show you're working on
this weakness or skills gap taking
Udacity course yeah most of you are
doing that that's often the easy one to
use for all of you so good good for you
implementing organizational tools maybe
it's using Microsoft teams or slack or
it's some type of prioritization
software a project management software
that's helping you get more organized
and and overcoming a certain weakness
maybe you found ways to tap into various
subject matter experts and the last
example was an HR manager maybe it was
someone and maybe it's the one in
back-end development who you've worked
closely with to try to learn more and
take on a little bit of responsibility
so you could learn more in that space
maybe it's taking a soft skills course
like presentation skills maybe it's
building a network of resources to tap
into so this is where it's really
important to think about your network of
people and people hear the word
networking we talk about it a lot but
even internally if you're working right
now think about who you can tap into to
learn something to grow to to tap into
their knowledge and start getting you're
working your way into that space where
you might want to be I'm talking
too much we need some other questions
okay
mirror is asking if the answer does not
convince the interviewer something you
just know what from their body language
you're asking some more lingering
questions around the same point what do
you do then that's a good question
actually this next slide I think it's
next let's just check here yes so quick
little tips and then I'll go little
deeper into your question try to be
concise and don't over share your
weakness I find a lot of people and
maybe American dove like you're saying
like they don't feel like the
interviewers their body language or
something like they're not getting it or
they're not hearing it so they just go
way too deep with the weakness you know
like maybe it's I wanna I'm gonna pick
on you because I've talked to you before
and I know that you'll laugh so let's
say go on is like super impatient and
she's like you know I'm just impatient I
throw things in my office I get really
mad when someone's late and um you know
I really lose my temper and then I'm and
then I just start going into this like
the spiral of like the worst maybe
impatient moment I had in my life that
is not gonna be good right you're you
start getting nervous it's over sharing
and and talk too much so always be
really concise with your weakness and I
wanna I know you don't have the
personality to do that that's why I
could pick on you a little bit there so
state your weakness quick avoid being
defensive don't worry with their body
language if they're not if you're not
convincing them or if they're if you
don't know if they're getting sometimes
the interviewers just thinking of their
next question and the last thing you
want to do is say like did this answer
your question was that enough do wait to
go into more detail or you talk more
about the weakness then you've just kind
of blown it up so with this particular
question be concise don't over share
definitely don't be defensive if they
say to you well did anyone ever complain
about your throwing things that seems
really unprofessional then you'd say
well I just threw it my own office and
you know whatever it might turn into and
this is obviously some crazy extreme
example that I just came up with in my
mind it's not gonna happen to any of you
but I have heard a lot of people
definitely giving too much detail about
their weakness and always focus more on
that step two if you need to go around a
little more if they keep linger on that
point always think about the things
you're doing to improve yourself where
you're wanting to grow and get better
always look on that step to how you're
developing it and don't dwell on the
weakness itself
and if they keep asking lingering
questions around the same point maybe
just again think of another example of
how you've gotten better at that and how
you know maybe at some point you just
have to say but that you really you
you're very aware of this and you've
made so much effort to develop it that
you're really proud of yourself and
feeling very confident and really bring
the confidence back to you and the
interview of that stage they're giving
it a hard time
all right let's see how I did on timing
pretty good so I had promised plenty of
Q&A time especially given this topic for
one but also the fact that I know many
of you have struggled recently to book
coaching sessions so I wanted to make
sure that this particular webinar was a
little bit shorter in content so that we
could open up and have Q&A so at this
point I will
I hope someone asks a question feel free
to unmute yourself turn your video on
ask a question whatever you want to do
I'm going to stop sharing my slide so
that I can see maybe who's talking if
you decide to turn your camera on and
remember any questions go it does not
have to be about this topic anything
about career coaching
can the slide be shared the yes they
will be on the YouTube channel you will
see all of the slides there and this has
all been recorded
questions questions questions about
Udacity career services questions about
career projects just no programming
questions please what somebody else
wants to answer hi this is Mita here
again hi hi I'd was taking a bit of time
typing so I just decided to unmute
myself sounds good so I know that many
of us like I have a career break and
that's what I'm trying to bridge I keep
studying online as well and interviewing
as well and we know that we very proudly
say we are doing the Udacity course or
this or that but being from the industry
on the hiring side do you see that as an
acceptable answer because very often I
get a feel that the recruiters are
looking for do you have like substantial
hard on the project kind of an
experience and many times it is like oh
these are our requirements and have you
exactly done these somewhere else all we
want is to change your address and come
down here so no matter how creative and
how confident Li we put it up it's like
can you demonstrate which was the last
project what was what was the duration
of it so there's just how do you tackle
this part when you have a gap in the
career yeah you know I think and that is
always the excuse me the struggle is to
is it is convincing them and I think
really making sure and it sounds like
you know what you're you're doing a lot
of the right things and unfortunately
there are a lot of recruiters out there
who do whatever the boxes ticked exactly
how they want it ticked and what's
important is to have not only pulled
from like yes the Udacity experience in
any any other projects and that's why we
say projects are always so important but
also making sure you pull from your
background what it what else what was it
what were some of those transferable
skills
and and just like for instance I talked
to someone today worked as a business
analyst for a few years and took a break
started taking digital marketing and it
was kind of like okay I can just show my
digital marketing and that's it I'm like
no that business analysts like you were
that took a lot of attention to detail
and analytical work that a lot of that
transfers over so finding ways that you
can bridge some of the work you did in
your past and what you've learned in the
Udacity course and really showing how
you can connect those dots for them to
give a really nice tight cohesive story
and there's a new book that was I think
just came out today
it's called either your turn or your
time and it's written by I think some of
the people with Athea pray group a PR es
and they help women they help men and
women but it's I think they started
mainly as helping women who had taken
career breaks and they just released
this book I'm excited to read it it was
either your turn or your time if you
don't see it send me a message and I'll
send you a link to it but I think that
there's a lot more openness to bringing
people back in after who have had career
breaks so I think that while you might
get across some recruiters who aren't as
open I think also getting with companies
and interviewers who appreciate what
you've done during the break whether
that was a class or ten projects or stay
home with your kids for half the time
and then started taking classes whatever
it was as long as you can connect those
dots and help them understand your story
thank you just a short to follow up on
this so when you are the projects that
you have done let's say I have my own
R&D lab and I keep working on things
what kind of bucket do I put it under on
the resume because you have like a
generally they would say client and the
duration and things like that so if I
were to put the things that I do with
either Udacity or I just found some
datasets somewhere and I work choose to
work on it how do I kind of bring it
together on the resume without
yeah okay okay say there's a couple ways
that I recommend and and you can kind of
see what you think might fit you best
one is just simply to have a project
section where you talk about it
sometimes when people have had a career
gap and most of what they've been doing
let's just say it's been two years
most of what they've been doing over the
two years is your own projects open
source or just getting that data set or
Udacity sometimes what they'll do in the
work experience is is put like the most
current role is it could either be
full-time student or independent studies
you can kind of call it what you want
and then in there say you know maybe you
have one sentence that says something
like Ben you know during this during
this time something where you would say
improving skills in data analysis and
data science through various courses and
projects and then you can kind of bullet
point those in that section okay thank
you
and both ways I think look good so you
can you know really just play around
with it and see what you like him and
maybe send it to the resume career
project to get review if you talk to a
coach or friends you don't see what
people like is I think either way would
work I have a website as well where I
post my stuff and I thought that people
would probably be attracted and read
that but not very often people still ask
you you know traditional questions and
anyway thank you yeah you're welcome
yeah Angela I had a follow-up question
to that so you mentioned that to put the
projects maybe in a current growth
section like for example I was working
last in me and now I'm not working right
you're saying like in the work
experience section have currently you
know first the audacity course and these
are the projects there or should I have
a project section where I mentioned
audacity projects work done and then
some of the projects done previously
because
in not projects I would say any big
releases I did earlier you know but
they're not exactly mapping to the
degree I'm doing you know right but but
not too much you know so I did as you
may reviewed by the resume critic on
Udacity they told me to create they
reviewed at once and they said to create
a careers a project section you know but
I wasn't sure I've never done that
before like what goes in there you know
yeah
yeah and it's it's can really be the
nice thing about the project section is
that you can really be as you can be
pretty creative with that right and what
I often tell people the most important
things on those projects is always give
it like a name so that which it seems
silly but let's say I know one of the
courses there's like a dog breed image
classification project you want to call
that something so let's just say you
call it the dog breed classification
project that way when when you're
talking about it you have you can refer
to it in the interview it gives it a
little identity it gives a little more
structure sometimes you just need one
basic sentence but you want to name it
you want to always show the technology
used like using Python bla bla bla bla
bla or if there were several
technologies used sometimes people just
put in parentheses at the end completed
with PI torch num PI's whatever it is
and then a date so those are them and
usually a source like if it was a
Udacity course or as open source and
kind of saying rows from so showing that
those projects in a special project
section is very good and then yes I also
said you can also put it in your work
experience if you've taken a break some
people even call it you know sabbatical
leave or they call it full-time student
or they call it independent research
whatever you want to call it whatever
you were doing and that since was it may
call that something and then in there
you can talk a little bit about bullet
point real quick what you've been doing
in and maybe even highlight or you can
in there may be say worked on multiple
data science projects using blah blah
blah blah blah and then in the project
section you're going until
more detail okay thank you yeah okay I'm
gonna maybe catch a couple of the
questions and the chat really quick here
so I'm concerned about that career link
has become a weakness in certain
industries should we limit the number of
previous jobs in our resumes and
LinkedIn profiles that's a good question
and there are people out there thinking
wait I don't have enough experience and
then there's other saying wait I had too
much experience so in this case he's
asking do I have too much experience and
then it may be age bias comes into play
a few things that a lot of people do and
a lot of people recommend now is to
first delete the years off of your
education so different people have
different rules of thumb some people say
if it's anything pre-2000 take the years
off some people say if it's anything
pretty 2010 whatever it is if you want
to take the years off your education
because you feel like it seems like a
long time ago that is completely fine
and then in terms of the oldest jobs I
think it is absolutely fine to omit
older jobs if you think you don't want
to take off so many that only looks like
you've worked three years either because
there is a lot to be said for
transferable skills and experience and
life and work experience so I wouldn't
go too extreme but you know I worked
with someone the other day and they had
two of their internships on there and
they've been working for about 15 years
so I said you know time to get the
internships off that's fine and also if
you do decide to keep some of the older
ones you can get less and less content
so that your your content is bigger and
your more recent jobs let's see there's
another chat question plummy I'm making
a career shifts I'm based in South
Africa and we need to get a remote job
once I'm ready to start applying I'm
happy to travel on a work visa if you
need it but the job would mostly need to
be remote can you tell me if it's
possible to get a remote job in the AI
field also are a few Udacity nanodegrees
an AI machine learning deep learning
enough to get a job in the AI field okay
so first it's interesting I just read an
article today about it was from a
recruiter in AI and data science from
their perspective they're seeing
they are definitely seeing a lot of job
growth still in this area and especially
growing outside of you know it used to
be all Bay Area San Francisco and New
York and they're definitely seeing hubs
opening up in a lot of different places
most of the article was still a little
bit us-based I think I read another
article that definitely said Berlin is a
big hotspot right now as far as Europe's
concerned so but talking about remote
work it said there's still very limited
jobs in data science and AI that are
remote at this stage but they think that
that's gonna start to grow and
especially this very senior levels
they're starting to be more remote
opportunities so I think you know as as
far as working remote there's a lot of
sites that we help people and guide
people to if they're looking I think
looking at some of those target cities
that do are a little more open I know
Berlin is one Toronto's another that a
lot of people when they're looking
internet for an international move tend
to be a little more friendly to people
kind of coming in is the nanodegree
enough to get in the job in AI field I
think that you know it really depends on
any other experience you have and the
type of role you can find I know some
people who have gotten some even just
entry-level more internship type roles
after taking a machine learning course I
would say more common is that people
have done several projects and then get
into there
I hope that helps let's talk about
curling okay to human are bought reap
uterus do most the resume screening
these days I think the first screening
is
that's a good so I think it's a mix I
think it's a human using a computer so I
guess I don't think it's like totally a
bot giving information but I think it's
a lot of humans especially on LinkedIn
that are filtering for the people they
want and that's where so much of the
keywords are important so that you don't
get filtered out too soon in the process
so make sure you know the keywords in
your particular field if you're not sure
one of the ways you can do it is copy
and paste five or six job descriptions
put them in like a Wordle where it pulls
out that the most common words they're
finding or even just reading them and
saying okay like this these the words I
keep hearing over and over and over and
making sure you're including those
and I think so I think the first filter
is often human but there's they are
filtering so they're certainly using
technology to filter their list and then
kind of as it gets down to a reasonable
number I think the hard thing is is
because of it being so automated the
number of resumes is so huge that they
have to use obviously some level of
technology and that's where having an in
with someone knowing anyone in the
company can always help LinkedIn just
announced last week that of they're
gonna have a lot of upgrades to their
jobs for the job seeker and one of the
things they talked about it and as far
as I know it hasn't hit yet but
hopefully will be coming soon is if you
apply for a job through LinkedIn it's
gonna pop up a message pretty quickly
that says you've applied for this job at
Google and your network you know seven
people who work for Google would you
like to ask them for a recommendation
and then you can basically click a
button and say yes and it'll go and
somehow it's going to ask those people
if they'll recommend you or so I thought
that sounded pretty exciting I don't
know all the details yet they just
announced it like I said last week so I
think that's where having that robust
network knowing people being connected
to people can help you again okay next
question sorry my scrolling a little too
quick okay I'm trying to fall to find
out if the job is I'm trying to find a
job as a data analyst completed the data
analyst and nano degree and working in
business data analyst but I can keep I
keep on getting rejections can you help
me with improving my approach so it's
hard to know without talking to you
personally about maybe your experience
or how your interviewing if you can tell
me are you getting um
automatic rejection so is it your resume
or is it first are you getting a phone
screen interview and you're not getting
an interview like and just not getting
past the first screen if you're not
getting any responses it's probably you
know maybe we can do some things for
your resume if you haven't done the
resume review project yet I reckon
doing that again making sure you have a
lot of the key words make sure you have
a project section so you can show the
work you've been doing and that should
help increase your chances of getting
that first role also if it is your first
job looking even where they're asking
for interns and if a company has very
big companies might be very specific
about the interns they'll accept what
year they are in school when they're
graduating but what I often recommend is
if you see companies that do hire
interns and you don't qualify based on
their intern criteria try sending a
resume to someone in that company
someone in HR and seeing if you can find
an internship maybe outside of their
kind of standard intern procedure okay I
see someone with their hand up I I
forget how to use this feature I'm going
to hit lower hand and then maybe then it
will let you talk let's see
are you there is it some puff
okay some puffs maybe you accidentally
raised your hand but if you want to talk
feel free to text it or unmute yourself
next question I'm in the bay area what
are the sights one can look for jobs
which are remote in the Bay Area okay
III can copy and paste those sites in
the chat maybe just in just a minute
I'll do that
where we get off okay for freelancing
jobs in the US which are the best
sources for analysts with predictive
analytics Canada jump I used up work for
some time so up work fiber and I think
it's freelance or freelancer are ways to
find those I think from what I've heard
fiber is hit or miss and I think it's
you're never going to make a living off
of it up work you can find opportunities
I think all Samara if you're looking for
freelance but are open to contract work
even finding a recruitment company that
that an IT consulting company that you
could get some contract worth work could
help as well
is it important to finish your degree
before applying to jobs isn't it good to
get some interviews experience before
one takes the real plunge maybe apply
and not so great companies and them
apply to good ones yeah I think I get
mixed feelings on this I have I have a
really I think it's tough to go into an
interview and give it your best shot
when you really don't want the job at
all I think it's a really hard situation
to put yourself in I think if it's a job
at least you're somewhat interested in
maybe that would work there's also a
site called which is peer-to-peer
interviewing help and you could look
into that to get a little experience I
think it's absolutely fine to start
applying if you're confident in your
skills to start applying while you are
completing the nanodegree is is
absolutely fine let's see
okay so cool sad back on that resume
conversation we talked about earlier his
it is the automatic rejection you're
getting so I would say definitely focus
in on your resume look for projects look
for keywords remember that first filter
might be happening from your resume so
and then go through and do another
Udacity career project and see if you
can get some more feedback as well I
returned to school to get a graduate
degree after a long work history what a
recruiters consent consider it as a
weakness not having an active work
status oh definitely not I think that if
you're
if you're in school full-time getting a
graduate degree then I don't think that
is a weakness at all and if they do
think it's a weakness then you need to
just convince them of everything you're
learning and how you're growing and how
you're going to use that combined with
your work experience to make you an even
better candidate what do you recommend
to someone who is a seasoned
professional an IT but a little practice
but little practical experience in data
science other than the courses what are
some approaches to land jobs in this
area I think that what a lot of people
do that I've talked to similar to you is
with getting date getting your hands on
data
there's tons of open source data where
you can get your hands on free data and
fight and creating your own projects
looking for open source projects and
really showing how you are able to
combine to use those new skills and then
again think of ways I know I keep saying
this but like think about ways like
sometimes I like if you really think
about like the job that helped you get
where you are what was it you did in
that job or learned in that job to make
you great at what you do now
and using those examples and pulling
extracting those highlights from that
past work experience and then showing
how you can use it in data science and
get your hands on data and see what you
can do okay Sam Huff i have a question
regarding OMS yes I would like to talk
about it next yes please unmute yourself
I'm not sure I'm remembering what OMS CS
samman some pops can you go ahead and
ask your question
I think you're unmuted but I can't hear
you okay let's see okay Rachel said feel
free to go this career channel or
student hub I know some people are
asking some private messages about how
else can we get a career session right
now the only thing we only way we can
book sessions is through the portal
again we have these new coaches starting
like so soon I'm not free to announce
anything at this stage but it's gonna be
very very soon and you will see
everyone's calendars showing much more
availability and I know that especially
Brett knife if you've talked to Brett
before we we do sometimes open things
last-minute usually not the day of but
sometimes I'll look at my calendar and
something frees up I had a cancellation
of something else and I'll try to open
up a few sessions so keep checking and
I'm sorry I know it's a little
frustrating that we are doing the best
we can and just we do have two minutes
left so I'm going to try to get to two
more questions so we can do here I'm the
press I'm in a chemical engineer with 26
years of experience I want to switch my
career into data science join Udacity
completed the programming and data
science with Python what is the next
nano degree I should focus on to move
with the data science career path oh I
wish I had like a really good answer if
there's someone on here that's done a
lot of the data science I would feel
love for you to chime in or Rachel I'd
have to talk to you more and really know
the other source I would say is to call
the Udacity advisor you set up an
appointment with the advisors and they
are much better at answering those
questions I don't want to steer you the
wrong way also the other thing you could
do is post that question
in if you're on slack or in the student
hub post that question into the career
section or also into your student group
and impose that question to your mentor
and I think by getting some feedback
from different people that you might get
a little more better direction than what
I'm doing right now mark thank you so he
says that the data analysts and data
engineering
nanodegrees so thank you and I think
from what I understand it's maybe you
figure out if which you prefer if you
prefer the more the data analyst side or
the data engineering side and see if
there's a specific direction you really
want to go with that
and as I am finishing up here I am
pulling up the remote job boards to put
in the chat group and they will be there
in just a second and then I'm gonna have
to jump off because I do have a coaching
call thank you everyone for joining I
really I loved having all the questions
it was fantastic I hope that it helps
you get a little bit closer to that
dream job that you're all going after
and I love hearing as you all land jobs
and you will I know that there are so
many students I hear from all the time
that are getting jobs and you know
there's always a lot to have that growth
mindset
there's always rejections on the way to
that job so don't get discouraged stay
positive and right now I'm going to post
there's some remote and overseas boards
and some freelance boards so I'm gonna
copy and paste all of these in here for
you all and I'll keep this on for a
minute so you all can copy and paste it
into whatever you want wherever you want
to save it that it yes still there oops
I think it just went to Mira hold on let
me get it to everyone
Mira I think you have it
now I think everyone has it yes all
right I'll give you all a minute to copy
and paste that and then I'm going to
have to sign off
more questions please reach out in the
student hub and Rachel I was trying to
remember our next events but I feel like
I'm just kind of running one event at a
time right now and I can't think of
what's next on the schedule so I'm sure
we'll have something next week and check
us out on YouTube I have teenagers I
tell them I'm a YouTube star but they
don't think it's funny I don't really
think it's funny either but I think it's
sometimes if you have teenagers it's
funny to make them crazy